hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
John Humphrey which one would you call
lady and which one would you call [ __ ]
come on let's face it I'm definitely the
lady here we're gonna watch the official
trailer for the Disney Plus movie show
movie movie yeah a whole show dedicated
to there's a lot to expand on here
anywho let's hop right into it
[Music]
ahahahaha
[Music]
let me guess you're like the center of
your people's universe right indeed well
I got Opie shoes
our fences is can the baby sound with me
it could be an adventure
oh good
[Music]
oh they own a bigger Avenger huh
[Music]
hey they're all back
[Music]
my god that looks so freakin adorable
that does look lovely I gotta say Wow
we're advertising it all at the end of
it we got our gathers marble there's
good bumper we're gonna see a whole
bunch of times for the near future
Wow wow that looks that looks so
touching really nice yeah I was
initially the first shot I was like oh
here we go
look to like a shot out of Mary Poppins
returns or Christopher Robin or
something but yeah this is just totally
endeared me right to it and when [ __ ]
starts talking ya ever I don't know if
it's because when we saw Lion King there
was something about the first time you
saw it in the trailer really looks a
little weird but something doesn't look
so strange about this one either
it'll be interesting to see because this
will be another attempt it seems that
marrying yes some kind of CG effect to a
real pair of dogs a real you know animal
cast yeah and yeah at least that one
shot that glimpse we got I thought was
actually pretty good you know like it
didn't seem to clash with the expression
in his voice and the motion looked fine
and dogs in and of themselves or yes you
know and and you also have just you know
the Lion King has all CG elements and I
think there is something just more
tangible about this ultimately and I
forgot about jock and trusty and they I
think this jock is being changed
right now Jackie I believe if IMDB is to
be trusted in feminism ruining my dog
he's so distracted the way I always am
when I look at a dog's face I'm gonna be
distribute and immediately tell its
gender that I don't really care this
looks super adorable and I I really love
lady in the [ __ ] the animated movie
weirdly for some reason I there watch
this I don't have any cynical thought of
all of like would just leave it alone by
the way it is there there's something
about this that seems very kind of
sincere actually yeah yeah it was like a
flavor maybe and Tad Khan because
they're real - actually yeah different
so yeah and I think there is something
that adds a sort of contrast in the
realm
of Disney live-action remakes reboots or
whatever this is this somehow doesn't
feel like it reminded me of some of them
but in a way that is yeah a bit more
genuine I mean not everybody liked
Christopher Robin but this gave me more
of that kind of yeah contained sense you
know and so it's we're gonna get to know
the owners a little bit better and I are
gonna be really stressed out about their
work and stuff by the end of it the lady
in the [ __ ] they're gonna fix it that
everyone's gonna take a vacation I feel
like I'll PI do some different things
with their adventure really I don't
remember I've seen that movie once I
think at the El Capitan years ago and I
don't remember the big steamship yeah I
don't remember that what I did notice
where are the racist stereotype Siamese
yeah whatever I'm all for switching
genders but no we need our Siamese cats
back in here that's for sure
conjoined cats that's the proper term
mmm
played by Aquafina this actually looks
really cute I know there's another trio
that job we should probably go check out
but yeah let's just talk about this for
20 minutes the trailer the dogs I mean
the poster the dog looks a little sad
but dog and some other things and let me
tell you guys are you excited for this
comment below this is the main reason
why people are subscribing in disney
plus you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification rule
again notified whenever we got a video
up and i like to have a patron the day
shout out to a lovely woman named Jen
Smith now Jen you've gotten to know John
quite a bit when talking about our
patreon page I've gotten to know you and
messages lately he's giving me some good
pointers on how to keep a long-lasting
marriage alive because I'm apparently
married and I wanted advice on how to
keep that flame know lit your marriages
is on the rocks we've been on the rocks
and she's been saving it total fandom
geek girl but also just a wonderful mom
and a wonderful wife you are such a
sweetheart I love getting to know you
just get a sincere shout out say hi to
your [ __ ] of a husband for me okay
you rock our socks and our shoes yes you
do and our shoes as well